everything's just so political now
everything's so politicized what side
are you on ah I don't know you both seem
[ __ ] annoying
that'd be a little this little that no
you gotta pick one well we don't do that
with bisexuals
isn't that weird we only have two
political parties all these major issues
two parties that's it we got 13 hbos
I don't even seem like the political
people like the government they don't
even give a [ __ ] about us you know just
feels like the right and the left are
our parents and they're divorced and
instead of trying to raise us well they
just want us to hate the other one
all right yeah your mom's a little
liberal your dad's a republican you know
they're trying to get you to live with
them yeah like come on dad mom gives me
free money he's like well she also tried
to abort you you're like dude
yeah
I live with you
but I don't know it's just good to be
back in Portland beautiful women in
Portland I mean none here
joking I'll go down on you but yeah